vacances ou pas les joueuses de
l'olympique lyonnais doivent garder la
forme
quelques foulées le temps d'un
échauffement loin du froid et des stades
wendy melvin et selma n'en n'oublient
pas leurs objectifs
lâchez rien c'est vrai que on profite
beaucoup de sa famille et
l'environnement mais après le haut
niveau reste le haut niveau voilà faut
continuer à travailler même en vacances
même là où n'importe quoi donc
donc c'est important c'est une
détermination à aller toujours plus loin
à se surpasser pour un jour espérer
égaler le palmarès de wendy renard
l'international est un exemple pour ces
jeunes sportifs de 19 ans s'était jusque
là exemplaire c'est comme une deuxième
maman pour moi elle est toujours là pour
moi et en dehors du terrain et sur le
terrain elles montrent le bon exemple et
pour tout les jeunes il faut sur cet
exemple parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un exemple en fait y'a pas de mots pour
sa souffrir au lendemain de noël
une habitude pour des joueuses de
football de haut niveau et le
préparateur physique ne les a pas
épargnés en cette trêve hivernale
bon on n'est pas sur des séances
en période de compétition il faut quand
même penser à la récupération mais c'est
très important de garder un niveau de
travail coct secteur connaît pas avoir
de derrière de grosses lacunes sur le
retour et éviter les blessures
wendy renard a proposé à ses deux
coéquipières de passer les fêtes de noël
avec elle en martinique
l'occasion de partager les traditions de
son île et d'épauler les deux jeunes
femmes
consciente d'être un exemple la sportive
en profite pour distiller ses conseils
je le fais naturellement parce que c'est
comme ça c'est de génération en
génération et j'essaye de leur
transmettre que le haut niveau c'est
l'exigence et c'est pas quand on arrive
sur le terrain qu'on l'a mais c'est tous
les jours au quotidien même quand on à
la maison même camp quand on est en
vacances c'est comme ça en fait s'il
faut savoir ce qu'on veut la carrière
elle est courte
une exigence partagée par toutes les
joueuses victorieuses de la coupe de
france des championnats de france et de
la ligue des champions 2010 9
on peut dire que ces vacances elles les
ont bien mérité